i i really wanted to wreck the swing
across because then you can stop those
type of moves nasty trap here from uh
david anton if you get greedy and grab
the black pawn the black rook was about
to come down and give a check to the
white king so white's king runs to
safety first i don't know why magnus did
this i mean just
i think he knows that this is he's going
to win the second pawn and it's quite an
easy
quite easy sort of winning position so
it's just fair enough there's probably a
couple of ways to i like your swinging
moves maybe he just did it because you
know he wanted to give some false hope
to david anton
cruel yeah cruel sadistic play so
possibly yeah you think it's a draw no
it's not right and this one is winning
two extra pawns now there are some
scenarios actually where the white eng
pawns together two extra pawns they
don't win the game um if you if the
black king is well placed so if the
white king is badly placed the black
rook can give some checks resigned there
we go two pawns are enough
black gives up and that means magnus
carlsen is ready for the semi-finals
after only 3